(whooshing)
(clicking)
(electronic tones)
(piano music)
- [Man] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked,
large brained,
long the master of fire,
tools and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves,
aware that death is inevitable.
Yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our
shared understanding of the past.
Carta brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are
and how we got here.
An exploration made possible by
the generosity of humans like you.
(instrumental music)
(upbeat music)
- So, let me talk about what we can learn
from congenital amusia.
First of all, I'd like to mention
that we are all born to
be musical and we all are.
That is musical engagement is ubiquitous
and emerges early in life,
and the best evidence
is really that newborns
respond to abstract
properties of musical pitch
and time structure, like
changes in tonal key
and disruptions of musical beat,
before the age of one.
We also move spontaneously to music
and when moved in symphony with music
they show enhanced pro-social behavior.
So, musical engagement is not only
rooted in social interactions,
but it also a highly
pleasurable experience,
and now we demonstrated now with dance.
This is not the prototypical
musical situation,
but think of it, it's
really a musical activity,
and I'd like you to pay
attention to the first row
and the last one,
and these are the two extremes
I am really interested in.
(uptempo music)
And I'm sorry, but I will
turn first to the ones who
don't have it.
That is they represent
1.5% of the population
and that is what I'm referring
to as congenital amusia.
I call it congenital for the idea
that it is present from birth,
defines a likely time period,
not the etiology.
Although we have made a lot
of progress regarding this.
What characterizing them,
it's their inability to detect
when someone sings out-of-tune
including themselves,
to recognize and sing
familiar tune without
the aid of the lyrics and
to maintain tunes in memory,
and what is really fascinating is that
it emerges just in isolation
from other disturbances
such as speech delay,
intellectual deficiency,
acquired brain damage or
even music deprivation.
The eyes go to music like we all are,
and they have normal understanding
of speech and prosody in everyday life.
It is also very similar to
other learning disorders
that you are familiar with,
like dyslexia for example,
speech disorders like
the one we heard earlier,
dyscalculia, prosopagnosia.
Why are we so interested
by these conditions?
It's because it is a natural experiment
of the neurobiological origins of music
because it is an accident of nature.
We didn't create it
and it is a rare chance to
link brain behavior and genes,
and also breakdown patterns,
reveal how the brain works
and I tried to illustrate each
of these points in a moment,
but I have to tell you how we do that.
So, we go from the behavior to,
and I will illustrate it so that
you will have an idea of what it is,
from a functional explanation
to the brain correlates
what are the anomalies in
the brain to the etiology
from the genes to the
environmental factor,
and I will illustrate it with someone
who just wrote a book about his condition.
(audience laughs)
Tim Falconer.
He was 54 when he came to visit my lab
and that's where he
discovered that he was amusic
because he only had one complaint
is to sing out-of-tune,
and I really invite you to read his book
which is a fascinating description
because he writes so beautifully as well
and has a very good sense of humor.
It just appeared last year,
but let me illustrate with his condition,
because we filmed him several times.
So, typically they fail
to detect pitch deviants.
Like here there are two melodies
and we ask them if it is
the same or different.
(beep)
(piano playing)
- I'm gonna say that was different.
I think there was an extra pause in there.
(beep)
(fast piano playing)
Same.
(audience laughs)
- And you could see on the face that
he couldn't tell.
He couldn't detect them.
Now, the best part.
So, we played with the melodies
so that the melody's one semitone apart
from the accompaniment.
This is really a disorder
related to pitch structure,
and they are insensitive
to this kind of change
while newborns are sensitive to this.
They do perceive this change.
So, let me play to you the first example,
and of course, we don't ask non-musicians
if it's dissonant or consonant.
We just ask if it's
pleasant or unpleasant.
(upbeat classical piano music)
- So, like 10 is really pleasant?
- [Woman] Yes.
- Uh...
(classical piano music)
Seven.
(audience laughs)
- And typically, we'd
say everybody laughs.
I don't understand why,
and this really the problem
with this condition.
They are unaware of what's happening.
They have no idea of what is wrong
and what is correct,
and they sing, most of
them sing out-of-tune
and they are unaware of it.
It's just because other people tell them
that they are a little bit off, like Tim.
He is not really off as you will see.
♫ Happy birthday to you
♫ Happy birthday dear Mehala
- But what is really
nice is when we ask him
to sing on la la la.
(Tim singing la la la)
(Tim laughs)
- [Tim] That wasn't even close (laughs).
- He knows that he doesn't
know what the tune is,
but he's improvising as
well as the whole family.
I'll give you an example later,
but what is really
interesting is this fact.
That in terms of, I mean
Tim must be average here.
Here are the amusics,
and we have a large pool of 38 amusics
and here are the controls.
So, each dot represents
the average of one subject.
Each syllable is really
analyzed syllable by syllable,
and as you can see they
do sing less in tune
than the controls.
100 cents means one semitone.
This is the building block
of the tonal western system.
It is two adjacent keys on a keyboard,
and as you can see they are
indeed deviant in those terms,
but what is very fascinating is that maybe
they're out-of-tune relative
to what they should sing,
but they are in key, that is the intervals
they are singing are really in the key,
or at least as well as controlled.
They don't make so many
errors in those terms,
and what is very interesting in that
when they improvise like Tim,
they really made fewer errors.
So, the idea is really we
should improvise a little more,
and it is hereditary,
and I'll play just the mother,
but this is really a
signature of the whole family.
I just don't want this
to be later on youtube.
- [Elsie] Elsie Falconer.
♫ Happy birthday to you
♫ Happy birthday dear friend
- Not everybody does.
I mean that's fantastic about this family
because most of them are affected.
These are the black shapes.
I mean most of them are.
Of course, a few are spared
so we can say it's not
really in the environment.
It is in their genes and we
knew it is really hereditary.
So, if you have one
relative in your family
or a close relative,
then they are 40% chance
of 10 times at least more chance at that
you have a risk for amusia.
So it is hereditable.
So we try to identify what
are the genetic variants
of this condition,
because it has been so
successful for speech disorders
and for the moment it
has been without success.
The only thing I can say
and still it is only getting finding
is that we have no
evidence of FOXP2 mutation.
So,
(audience laughs)
it's like finding a needle in a haystack,
but we will continue
because I really think that
this is worthwhile because it has been
found for speech disorders
and likewise I believe that it
may provide new entry points
to the neurobiology of
learning disorders in general,
not just amusia,
and to do so, what is very important
is to know what is happening in the brain
and we do know a lot about
the neural correlates of this disorder
because it its a cortical disorder.
Here, back to Tim, we measured
the arcuate fasciculus.
This is a major fiber tract as illustrated
on the right side of my brain that relates
the auditory cortex to the
inferior frontal cortex
on the right side of the brain,
and as you can see Tim here is in read
and it's much smaller than a control
illustrated here in blue,
but of course, you conclude
that across many different
in music cases and you
compare that to controls
and it has been found in
many different studies
that they do have a connectivity issue.
So, the main problem with their brain
is a reduced connectivity
between these two regions,
the auditory cortex and
the inferior frontal cortex
and it is within terms
of functional anomalies
as well as structural anomalies.
We do find structural anomalies
in the auditory cortex
and the inferior frontal cortex
by having more gray matter,
but it doesn't seem to
lead to deficits in functioning
and so, a working hypothesis,
explanation of the
disorder now is in term,
at least it's mine, it is in
terms of recurrent processing
between the auditory cortex
and the inferior frontal cortex
and the idea that they do
have intact representation
of musical pitch in the auditory cortex,
so the bottom-up information
is reaching really their brain,
but they have poor feedback control
between the right inferior frontal cortex
and the auditory cortex,
so the top down aspects.
This is illustrated here.
So, the information is reaching
the auditory cortex correctly,
but it is really this loop that
might function in their case,
so that the auditory cortex
is really encapsulated.
It's not influenced by the way
they are processing or wanting to process.
So, let me just illustrate
that with the EG recordings.
We did use different
neuroimaging techniques,
but this one is really the
most revealing in this aspect.
So, we presenting melodies like this
and ask them if there's any incongruity.
So, the first one.
(keyboard playing)
You should say that's fine.
There is an incongruity
if you're not amusic.
Otherwise, there is no
overlap in distribution.
So, these are the amusics
and these are the controls.
Each bar represents one subject,
but what was really fascinating
and it has been replicated later on
is that we found a negative,
early negative response
in the brain of amusics as
well as in controls here,
and why we only found a P600.
That means that they are
consciously detecting
the deviance, the pitch deviance
accompanied by P600 only in
controls and never in amusics.
So, we have a clear signature here
of what's going on in their brain.
The auditory cortex which
is really responsible
for the N200 is responding
to the deviance,
but it's not integrated consciously
and it's not a problem of attention
because we have designed the situation
where we controlled for attention.
In this case, it was a
click they had to detect.
We replicated the same findings.
So, this explains why
I believe it is a question of
intact bottom-up information
because the N200 also called ERAN
or Mismatched Negativity
seems to be replicated
and reflect this bottom-up processing.
While the feedback revealed
by the P300 or P600
reflects poor control between the
right inferior frontal gyrus
and the auditory cortex,
and it is really a
pitch awareness disorder
because it's really so high level,
the pitch regularities of
tonal music are registered
and predicted by the auditory cortex
of the amusics without
leading to conscious report,
and what is really missing is
a normal feedback loop
to learn from errors,
and it seemed that really error correction
requires intention and/or awareness.
So, to summarize what have we
learned from congenital amusia.
Here are only the things currently
that I think are the most important.
First of all, conscious
error correction is a really
fundamental principle of
how the human brain learns
and we are not always conscious
of the way we correct ourselves.
Of course, during learning
when we are very young.
Also, function specialization can emerge
from distributed brain networks.
It's no longer the case
where you can think
of the brain like a really
focal brain regions.
It is a distributed neural
network as I have illustrated,
and a developmental anomaly can disconnect
the nodes of a network
and give rise to severe
yet specific learning disorders,
and finally, the right
fronto-temporal connectivity
seems to be essential to develop
a normal cognitive system for music,
but I'd like to finish,
to end on a positive note,
because I'm interested in those ones, too.
That are the ones that dance so well,
and this is really
something we are starting,
studying what I believe
are the other extremes,
the high end of the spectrum,
those of the musical prodigies
and I'd like just for you to listen to
a young, an Indian prodigy
like this one at the age of nine
and I will decrease.
(Indian music playing)
And it goes on for five hours.
(audience laughs)
It does, it does,
and here at the age of four.
(singing in a foreign language)
(Indian music)
And at one year, I mean before speaking.
(drumming)
He has support for sure,
but I'd like to understand how is
it possible to have this
kind of performance?
So, I do consider them
as congenital anomalies,
happy ones of course,
because there are recent findings showing
that really genetic
endowment is more predictive
of musical achievement than the
number of hours of practice.
That even the propensity to practice
appears to be under genetic influence.
(audience laughs)
You laugh, but this is a result
of a large sample of twins studied
and the learning outcomes can be predicted
by the preexisting structural
and functional brain features.
So, I'm afraid if you are not a prodigy,
you may not have it.
So, musical prodigies provide
really an ideal paradigm
for investigating the
neurobiology of musicality
and that to which I'm now
turning for the future.
So, I hope in maybe in 10 years from now
to give you a key or the code of something
of access or entry points
to this special talent.
So, thank you for your attention.
(applause)
- So, I'd like to tell you a bit about
a young man who I've worked
with now for 32 years I think,
Derek Paravicini.
Here's a picture of Derek
at 26 weeks when he was born
weighing a little over 700
grams, about 1 1/2 pounds.
So, Derek could literally fit on the palm
of an adult's hand,
and he had a fierce fight for survival.
This was 38 years ago.
So, the kind of therapeutic treatments
for very premature infants
were still quite primitive.
For example, there was no way of measuring
Derek's oxygen saturation
levels consistently.
So, to measure oxygen, they
had to take a tiny drop
of the blood from his finger,
rush off to the machine to measure it.
It took 1/2 an hour by which time
of course the oxygen had fluctuated again.
So, no surprising really
that Derek developed
retinopathy of prematurity
which is when the blood vessel
in the back of the eye
forces the retina forward
and his early development
was also very delayed.
He was later diagnosed with
severe learning difficulties
with a verbal IQ of about 57 and autism.
As a child his speech
was largely echolalic.
So, he rather than sort of
speak with semantic understanding,
he tended to repeat back
whatever was said to him,
but the very good news
was he was brought up by
a traditional British nanny
and she was determined
that Derek was going
to make the best of his life
whatever that was going to be,
and she went up into the
attic one day despairing
of finding something to entertain Derek,
and she found this old
toy really, toy keyboard
which she plugged in and gave to him,
and not thinking anything of it.
In fact Derek just seemed
to bash this thing for ages,
and then suddenly they
realized that in fact
he wasn't bashing around in there,
he'd actually taught
himself to play chords
and then tunes just through
a process of self-discovery.
I met up with Derek when
he was four years old
and he'd already built up a
large repertoire of pieces.
Now, he no tuition, of
course he had no visual model
to guide because Derek was totally blind.
He had very small hands,
he was only four years old,
and as a consequence he got
a very eccentric technique
as you can see from the pictures.
So, there was a lot of karate
chops and fists and knuckles
and even the occasional nose went down
to pick out notes he couldn't hear.
By great good fortune, that same nanny
who was responsible for Derek's upbringing
would press the button
on the tape recorder
and just briefly and so
we've got a little fragment
of what it was like to
hear Derek's playing
when he was four years old.
Here's a little bit.
See if you recognize it.
(piano playing)
Any offers?
(audience answering)
Yes, Schubert.
So, good old Derek.
I mean it's just a miracle.
Here's a boy who understood
virtually nothing
about the world around him,
really no useful language,
and yet without any
encouragement to start with,
he taught himself to play the piano.
One of the great human accomplishments.
I think the important thing about that
early recording though, it
shows a lot about the way
that Derek's musical mind was working.
For a start, he wasn't
just copying what he heard
because the recording you
heard was a voice and piano
so he had to rearrange that duet for
a single instrument of course.
Also, because he had such small hands,
he had to change the spacing of the chords
in order to be able to play them
and so, the result really
to me provides evidence
of genuine musical intelligence
and indeed the beginnings of creativity.
We've heard that savants
are more than just mimics.
I think Derek even in
that very early stage
shows a genuinely creatively
musical mind at work.
Just to show you a bit about Derek.
Today, he's now aged 38.
I think he's been to
California about six times now.
So, he's very cross he's not
here today I can tell you
because he, although he doesn't
enjoy 12 hours on a plane,
he does enjoy making music when he lands,
but he now has his own jazz quartet,
and I think music for him is so much
more than just a technical exercise.
It's genuinely a social and
emotionally fulfilling activity.
It's incredibly important for
his identity and self esteem.
If you ask Derek what he does,
he says, "I'm a pianist."
It's important for friendship,
for shared feelings
and even for humor.
So, here's Derek playing today.
If I ask you to guess the piece initially,
you might be wrong.
So, there's a warning.
This is Derek being witty.
(tune of Beethoven's
Moonlight Sonata playing)
♫ Night and day
♫ You are the one
♫ Only you beneath the moon
♫ And under the sun
- Now for later on in the track.
(upbeat jazz tempo)
♫ Night and day
- So, you can see how Derek's evolved
hopefully in the intervening 32 years.
So, what kick started
Derek's musical learning
and how is it he can do what he does?
Indeed with Leslie Lemke as well,
and it's the same unusual
skill as all musical savants
and indeed all musical prodigies rely on
which is universal absolute pitch.
Now absolute pitch is
the ability to reproduce
and to recognize pitches.
Not only in music, but in
any environmental sound.
It starts very early.
It's generally in place by 24 months.
It's interesting seeing
that young Indian drummer.
I've certainly seen young
blind children, aged 12 months,
start to play the piano.
By 18 months absolute pitch is in place
and they play pieces in the right key.
So, if these abilities are going to start,
they're going to start very early.
So, absolute pitch is very rare in
western populations as
a whole, about .01%.
Doing that kind of meta
analysis of all the literature
I can find plus all the blind
children I've worked with
which is hundreds over the years.
Something like 45% of
those who are born blind
or who lose their sight early on,
they're one to develop absolute pitch.
Among partially sighted
children it's around 11%
and around those on the
autism spectrum around 8%.
So, you can see there
something massively different
going on with a fair
proportion of these children.
It's interesting about whether
it's genetic or environmental.
I think one can debate,
because it's nothing genetic
about Derek's musicality.
I think it's the fact that
he was born blind that made
the structural differences to
the way his brain developed.
In fact, I think it's
larger to do with his
exceptional early cognitive
environments that blindness
or visual impairment and autism create.
Presumably there must be
a genetic component, too,
because not all blind children develop AP.
What it is it's a focus on
absolute perceptual qualities of
things for their own sake that
seems to make the difference.
So, I'll play you, one
wonderful thing about Derek,
is he loves psychological experiments.
He never gets bored.
(audience laughs)
I do with this one particular experiment,
I'm gonna play a bit of
it when I play him 120
different chords which
would drive anyone crazy
and ask him to play them back.
Most people freak out after
about 20 of these things,
and after the end of a
hard day's of analyzing,
taking data from Derek, he'd say,
"Can we do the chords
again tomorrow Adam?"
I said whoa Derek.
(audience laughs)
Right, so here's a sample
of those 120 chords.
If there's someone with
absolute pitch in the audience,
you might be able to pick out the notes,
but this is the only
information Derek got,
and I guess most people wouldn't be able
to tell you how many notes are in chord,
let alone what notes were being played.
Here's a sample of them.
(piano chords playing)
So, how many notes were in the last one?
No, I wouldn't have a clue.
There were nine in fact.
(piano chords playing)
Here's the chords
and here's Derek's responses.
This is me.
(piano chords playing)
This is Derek.
This is me and Derek.
We're on the second line.
(piano chords playing)
In fact, what Derek does
is you might pick up,
he actually adds notes in typically.
He very rarely misses them out.
So, here are Derek's
stats from the 120 chords.
There's four, five, six,
seven, eight and nine notes.
You can see he got all the four note
chords absolutely right.
He got about 96% of the five notes
and so I'm down to about
93% of the nine notes.
In fact, some it was interesting
seeing the bit from 60 Minutes
because Leslie Style
interviewed Derek at some length
and got him to play 10 note chords,
and he was still about
92% which is amazing
when you think the shear motor programming
to get 10 fingers over the right notes
at the right time is extraordinary,
but again interestingly,
it's not this sort of myth
of savants as kind of super human beings
that just don't conform to the rules
that the rest of us play by.
For example, Derek did much
better with tonal chords
than what you might call non-tonal.
In other words, standard western
tonality Derek's better at.
He was also more successful from
the bottom of the chords up.
So in other words, he was
listening more structurally.
Most of us when we listen to music
we tend to here the melody line.
Skillful musicians tend to
hear it from the baseline up
because that's telling them structure.
So, in other words, Derek was listening
with musical intelligence.
He wasn't just a perceptual
machine who had been copying,
and in fact we look at how Derek
did compared with other savants
and with experts, what you might call
neurotypical musicians
with absolute pitch,
you can see in fact there's
a fairly continuous distribution.
Derek's at the top,
the top blue line with s.
The other savants are in solid lines,
and then the neurotypical
musicians with absolute pitch
are in the dotted lines,
and I'm quite sure if
I find enough subjects,
there'd be quite a
continuous distribution.
So, in other words, the
savants are using the same
strategies as the skillful,
trained musicians.
So, as I said, it suggests
that these people live,
exist on a continuum
and that both use the same structurally
based listening strategies.
Right, another study now.
Long term memories, a feature
of all musical savants
as Darold said and sometimes this is said
to be eidetic or photographic memory.
Is that in fact true?
Right, here's another
mean test that people
think you must be mad doing this.
So, I composed a special new piece
of music for Derek to learn.
You have to compose something
because if he's heard it,
then he's probably already remembered it,
and all he did was to
hear it and play it back.
So, imagine that you're
sitting down at the piano,
you haven't got the music in front of you
and you hear this:
(Chromatic Blues playing)
(applause)
Thanks.
So, how much do you reckon
he'll be able to play?
Well, I'll show you what
Derek did in a minute.
Just to say this was
quite a long term study.
Over four years, we did 26 sessions
with increasingly long breaks in between,
two days in the first case
and two years in the last one,
and each session after the first,
Derek tried to play
whatever he'd remember.
He then listen to Chromatic Blues again,
attempt to play it once more
and the listened once
more to Chromatic Blues.
So, his very first attempt
he'd just heard exactly what
you've heard and in fact, he
got about 30% of it right.
Here is his.
(Derek playing Chromatic Blues)
Not bad Derek.
Of course, this shows you
know, one of the real dangers
I think of a lot of savant studies,
is that unless you do a
pretty systematic analysis
it's terribly hard to know.
In other words, if I just
played that piece in a concert,
this so often happens
people play Derek something
in a live situation, he then plays it back
and of course no one knows
if he's got it exactly right
or not because we haven't got Derek's ear.
So, I think a lot of
savant myths are built on
slightly devious anecdotes shall we say.
So, what did Derek do?
What's he going on there?
Well, it evidently beyond the
capacity of his working memory,
but he couldn't help but produce
something that made musical sense.
In other words, he's using
music like a natural language.
In the same way if we record a story,
we don't get every not right,
but we get the overall structure right,
we get the meaning right.
That's what Derek did.
He got the feel of the music right.
He got the overall structure right
and he got some of the detail right,
but it wasn't completely right.
So again, we see creativity coming in.
Derek had to be musically creative
in order to make ends meet.
So, what did he do?
Well he used the musical
fragments in a different order.
In order to make them fit,
he had to transform them in real time
and he introduced stock phrases
from sort of Rhythm and Blues style,
from Count Bassie, from
Blues turnaround and so on.
So, in other words, Derek's
functioning exactly like
a skilled jazz musician would
function in that context.
So, in fact he's anything but
this kind of photographic memory.
It's a characteristic
of a neurotypical recall
and in fact here's a comparison with Sacha
who is an expert neurotypical jazz pianist
with absolute pitch whom
we gave the same test to,
and you can see that Derek out performs
him after the initial burst,
but essentially Sacha's
doing not badly at all.
Much better than most of us would do,
and the analysis shows he was using
very similar strategies to Derek.
You can see that Sacha
gave up long before Derek.
Derek carried out for another two years.
In fact occasionally now he'll say,
"Can I do Chromatic Blues Adam?"
I say, no, no, no.
Right, last of all,
very often I get asked
and Derek gets asked
what about modern music,
this problem atonal music
it's sometimes called?
Now, atonal music was
introduced by Schoenberg amongst
others at the beginning of the first half
of the 20th century I suppose,
and it consciously avoids traditional
musical grammar syntax and rules
and most listeners report
finding atonal music discordant.
In other words, it sounds
like there are mistakes in it
and it's very difficult to remember.
Schoenberg said all he
wanted was for people
to whistle his tunes in the street,
but not a gooder.
(audience laughs)
In fact Tchaikovsky
annoyed him particularly
because people would
whistle Tchaikovsky tunes.
So, how did Derek get on?
Well, I gave him a bit of Schoenberg's
first atonal masterpiece
as called to try and play.
So again, if you close
your eyes and just pretend
to be Derek, this is what he heard.
(Schoenberg Klavierstucke
Op. 11 No. 1 playing)
How did he get on?
How do you think he did?
Well, here's a young man
who can hit nine note chords
with 93% accuracy.
He couldn't do it.
He completely couldn't do it.
Here's the original first phrase,
(Schoenberg Klavierstucke
Op. 11 No. 1 playing)
and here's Derek.
(Derek playing piano)
So, you can see even his absolute pitch,
his flawless absolute pitch was confused
when there's a lack of
background syntax rules.
I found it quite extraordinary.
I thought I had to check the equipment.
I thought Derek you got
the first note wrong.
I've never heard him
make a mistake like that.
So in other words, the atonal,
the music without rules
even confused Derek's perception.
Just a time to play you a little bit
of what happened a week later.
I'd asked him to play it a week later,
and the result he'd stepped
back from Schoenberg
into the world of Wagner.
It's extraordinary.
Here's a little bit of it.
(Derek playing piano)
So, I noticed Derek had
corrected the wrong notes.
(audience laughs)
So, in conclusion,
Derek and other savants,
I've had the great pleasure to have worked
with about six prodigious savants,
have an unusual degree of expertise,
but his engagement appears
to be qualitatively similar
to neurotypical musicians
with absolute pitch.
In other words, it seems
to be a matter of degree
rather than a fundamental difference,
and I'd like to thinking
that perhaps we'll gain more
insights about neurotypicality
by looking as it were
the opposite way, right.
We tend to view savants from
the view of neurotypical
of sort of mean based psychological tests.
Whereas in fact, if we look
at the world of the savants
and see what lights can
they shed on all of us,
we might be in a stronger
position in some ways.
Ultimately, I think we're all a part
of the same continuum
of human neurodiversity.
Thank you.
(applause)
- Darold Treffert could
not make it in person,
but he did manage to video tape the talk.
(mid tempo music)
- [Narrator] The human
brain is the most mysterious
piece of matter on Earth,
and the more we know about it,
the more magical the
whole system seems to be.
However, it is only
now in the 21st century
with new techniques that scientists
can for the first time
open up the secret chambers
in our heads and watch the complex system
of hundreds of billions
of neurons at work.
Among scientists most
fascinating subject of study
are a small group of enigmatic talents.
The so called savants.
Then knowing ones.
Savants can multiply five
digit numbers in their heads
or know 12,000 books by heart
or play a melody on the piano
after hearing it only once.
Over half of savants are autistic.
Others developed this super human
talents only after a brain injury.
Experts all over world are
now starting to ask themselves
is it in fact a defect that
turns a person into a genius?
Is there a hidden genius within all of us?
- Until we can understand the savant,
we can't understand ourselves
and no model of brain
function is gonna be complete
until it can fully account
for this incredible disparity.
Hello from the Treffert Center
in Fond du Lac, Wisconsin.
A unit of Agnesian HealthCare dedicated
to better understanding the human brain
and human potential.
What I want to do today is to share
some things that we do
know about savant syndrome.
120 years later after J. Langdon Down
first described savant syndrome.
Savant syndrome is a
remarkable condition in which
persons with a developmental
disorder, including autism
or other central nervous
system disease or injury,
have some astonishing islands of genius
that stand in marked, jarring
contrast to overall handicap.
Savant syndrome occurs in
approximately one in 10 persons
with autism and in approximately
one in 1400 hundred persons
with other development disabilities
or other central nervous system disorders.
Since these other developmental disability
and central nervous system disorders
are more common than autism,
it turns out that approximately
75% of savants are autistic
and 25% have other central
nervous system disabilities.
Therefore, not all savants are autistic,
and not all autistic persons are savants.
Savant skills occur on a spectrum.
First are splinter skills.
The second level are talented savants
and the third level
are prodigious savants.
Prodigious savants are
persons whose skills are so
remarkable that they're called prodigy
or genius if they were to occur in
a person without disability.
Savant syndrome I always
associated with a massive memory,
a memory that is extraordinarily deep,
but very narrow within its confines.
Savant skills typically increase
and persist rather than
diminish or disappear.
Savant abilities are not frivolous.
Instead they can act as a
conduit toward normalization
with an increase in language abilities,
social strengths and daily living skills.
I met my first savant in 1962.
Now 55 years later, it's rather hard
to summarize in 18 minutes
my journey with savants.
So, what I want to do
instead is concentrate
on the savant I know
best who's Leslie Lemke
who demonstrates many
of the characteristics
of savant syndrome.
I have known Leslie Lemke for 30 years.
He is a prodigious musical savant.
Like all savants he knows
things he never learned.
He instinctively knows the rules of music
put there by genetic memory.
Genetic memory which congenital
and acquired savants demonstrate is
the genetic transmission
of knowledge equals nature
and it can be expanded by
learning which equals nurture.
♫ It's so nice to have you back
♫ Where you belong
- [Narrator] It's hard to
say what's more striking
about Leslie Lemke.
His skills as a pianist
or his amazing life story.
(slow tempo music)
Leslie was born with cerebral palsy
and a rare disease that
necessitated the removal
of his eyes when he was
only a few months old.
Many might pity, but who could handle
the challenge of raising such a child?
May and Joe Lemke of
Milwaukee, Wisconsin did.
They adopted Leslie when
he was just six months old.
Using patience and love
as their inspiration,
May and Joe worked with
Leslie attempting to achieve
not the miraculous, but the mundane.
Functions such as walking, swallowing
and eventually swimming all took effort
and endless practice.
It seemed the only way Leslie
would ever even approach
a normal life would be through a miracle.
Late at night one evening,
a miracle did occur.
- When he was about 14 years old,
they watched a Sunday night movie
which happened to be Sincerely Yours
and the theme song is
Liberace's theme song
which is Tchaikovsky's
first piano concerto.
They watched and Leslie
listened because he's blind
and they went to bed
and then about two or
three in the morning,
May woke and heard some music coming
and she asked Joe, "Hubby
did leave the television on?"
No, and so there was Leslie playing
Tchaikovsky's first piano
concerto from beginning to end
having heard it one time.
- And I said to Joe, hey Joe,
did you leave that television on?
He said, "No, why?"
I said listen, where's that
beautiful music coming from?
And he said, so I got up,
went to the boy's room
and I had got that
little piano in his room
and the boy had suddenly
slid over like this,
onto that chair, played
all the way through.
(piano music)
- Leslie is blind, has spastic diplegia
and has never had a
piano lesson in his life.
Leslie knows things he never learned.
That is genetic memory.
Leslie has a measured IQ of 68,
but in this segment instead
of asking Leslie to play
a piece after hearing
it for the first time,
he is asked to play the
piece with the person.
Leslie then plays with the
person receiving processing
and outputting simultaneously.
That's called parallel processing.
That is not consistent with an IQ of 68.
IQ testing in savants is not reliable.
Savants point in the direction
of multiple intelligences.
(piano music playing)
Leslie has shown a transition from recall
to improvisation to
creation as all savants do
if followed long enough.
Savants can be creative.
In his concert now,
there is always an
audience request portion.
In this 2015 concert, Mary, May's daughter
asks Leslie to play audience requests.
- All right, let's go.
See how fast we can do this.
Eternal, I don't know
if he knows these now.
I'm just gonna play through
and like you know about Leslie,
he will never deny he doesn't
know one of the songs.
He's always gonna say
yes and he will play it
and if he doesn't get
the one you've requested,
he's making one up.
(audience laughs)
That's what he does.
This one's called Eternal
Father, The Navy Hymn.
He don't know it.
(Leslie playing)
I don't know if that's right.
Is that right?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
(applause)
(piano music)
Those Endearing Young Charms,
an old Irish song.
I don't know think he knows this one.
You know this one?
- Yes, I know it.
- Those Endearing Young Charms?
♫ Those endearing young charms
♫ Til the day that I knew
- You making it up?
♫ I'll
- Yes, I'm making it up.
(audience laughs)
♫ The God
♫ The rose
(applause)
(Leslie singing)
♫ These endearing young charms
♫ On the way
(applause)
♫ I know wonder la la
♫ For the dee dee dee
- This a pretty good one, isn't it?
(audience laughs)
(Leslie singing)
- Where'd you hear that one?
- On television.
- We don't watch television.
- No, you don't?
(Mary laughs)
- No, we don't.
(Leslie singing)
♫ These endearing young charms.
(wild applause)
- Leslie demonstrates that
savants can be creative.
They are not mere tape
recorders or copy machines.
If you follow savants long
enough there's a transition
from massive recall to improvisation
to creation.
Savants can be creative and
Leslie demonstrates that.
Supporting and loving
families are such a vital part
of bringing savant
syndrome into full bloom.
May Lemke, the woman who
willed a miracle, died in 1993.
In her final years may had
developed Alzheimer's disease.
Just before her death, Leslie
played for her one more time.
Just as she brought him to life,
his music lifted may from her
Alzheimer's disease for a brief time.
A fitting payback of love
and the power of music.
♫ Then sings my soul
♫ My Savior, God, to Thee
♫ How great thou art
♫ Then sings my soul
♫ My Savior, God, to Thee
♫ How great Thou art
(soft music)
- I think Daniel's ability
is at a prodigious level
because it would be
spectacular if that were
to be seen in any of us.
It would be spectacular.
- [Narrator] Equally though,
Daniel has been blessed
with almost miraculous good fortune.
The line between profound talent
and profound disability seems really
and surprisingly ephemeral.
The way Daniel can
describe his inner world
is giving scientists a
window into the brain
that they've never had,
but the truth is their journey of
exploration is only just beginning.
- The bigger question
is whether we all have
some of those abilities within us
and that is what I refer to as
the little Rainman within each of us.
What I do it isn't,
I don't thinks it super much.
I don't think it's something
that can't be explained.
Who knows there may be abilities here
that everyone can perhaps tap into
in some way.
- Savant syndrome is challenging us
to think in new ways about intelligence
and what intelligence is.
(soft music)
- Savant syndrome has
tremendous implications
for better understanding both the brain
and human potential.
Savants are not mere copy
machines or tape recorders.
They can be creative with a metamorphosis
from recall to improvisation
to creation.
You can explore this in more detail
at www.savantsyndrome.com
or www.treffertcenter.com.
Dedicated to preserving, sharing
and expanding research
into savant syndrome,
other forms of exceptional
brain performance
and human potential.
(soft music)
(upbeat music)